billionaire investor Warren Buffett is
betting big on semiconductors and
microchips Mr Buffett's Berkshire
Hathaway confirmed it had taken a 4.1
billion dollar stake in tsmc the
Taiwanese company is one of their
largest chip makers in the world
supplying an estimated 90 of the world's
super Advanced computer chips for Tech
giants like apple and Qualcomm
for more let's bring in DW correspondent
Sarah Lee and Taipei Sarah Warren
Buffett's investment firm does not
normally make big technology bets but it
often does prefer companies it perceives
to have a Competitive Edge what does
this investment mean then for tsmc
okay so it's definitely great news for
tsmc and its shareholders so after the
news came out the share price of tsmc
ADR Rose by over 10 and tsmc also told
the local media that quote it welcome
all investors who wish to buy and how
its shares in the long term unquote and
it also boosts confidence in tsmc's
prospects so some experts pointed out
that it's not very common for Warren
Buffett to choose tsmc over Intel just
when the US is trying to build up its
own semiconductor industry and second
um the Warren Buffett is a very
legendary investor he tends to invest in
great businesses that are currently
trading for a lower price than their
true value so all the situations tend to
prove that tsmc look more trustworthy
and profitable in the long term Sarah
semiconductors are probably the most
crucial product in the U.S China trade
dispute why is the United States so Keen
to stop China getting hold of microchips
from the U.S and its allies like Taiwan
um there are probably two main reasons
for this the first one is because the
military competition between the U.S and
China as a lot of people know a lot of
like jet fighters missiles and also some
battleships need these powerful
microchips in order to work so the US is
probably trying to prevent China from
getting these cutting-edge microchips to
strengthen its military power and
secondly it's probably because of the
economy
as you know a lot of Industry rely on
semiconductors and these chips so the US
is very likely to prevent China to get
these Advanced computer chips such as
csnc's products to bring its technology
to the next level
also the meeting of U.S President Biden
and China's leader XI on the sidelines
of the G20 Summit seems to Signal an
easing of tensions about Taiwan has this
been a boost to local investment
sentiment
um yes but to be honest it's not a very
significant boost on after the two
leaders met the overall stock market in
Taiwan only Rose by one percent it's
similar to what happened when Xi Jinping
and Biden had a phone call during the
pandemic so I would say it's not a
significant rise in general but it did
reduce the geopolitical tensions as
Biden after meeting said that he did not
think China had imminent plans to invade
Taiwan so it kind of fly said investors
at ease because in the past few months
China performed a lot of military drills
around Taiwan after Nancy Pelosi's visit
and he continued to claim that Taiwan is
part of its own territory so now
inventors are not so worried about the
situation and they they are kind of
reassured that Taiwan is a relatively
safe place to invest in
DW Sarah Lee and Taipei Sarah thank you